it's amazing to see everybody come
together each October to support breast
cancer awareness
but there's one athlete who went way
past just wearing pink look at this post
about former running back DeAngelo
Williams in honor of his mom and several
aunts who died from breast cancer he
paid for mammograms for 500 women and he
does
[Applause]
okay so first of all you are a great man
like you're just a great example of a
man thank you so much first of all for
that about your foundation so my
foundation started in 2006 that's when I
obviously I got drafted and stuff like
that my forearms and my mom was all they
all care to bracket 1g and after 2006
you know I'd already lost three aunts to
the breast cancer and then no in 2014 I
lost my mom and mother before that so I
lost my forearms and my mom to it so
it's not lost them to that disease I
started this because I didn't want
anybody else to feel the way that I felt
so in 2014 we started 253 strong for my
mom she was 63 years old and we get
those mammograms and that's how we
ultimately get five hundred it is pretty
good but I'm not I'm not there yet where
I want to be in terms of you know I want
to save every life that I possibly can
but at the same time I I don't know if
you know this but there's no cameras we
do stuff like this because I don't do
this for clinics likes or follow I do
this the same live I don't want anybody
you're a very good man
what what's next for you and the
foundation well this is my ultimate goal
we've given mammograms in four different
states we want to do it all 50 states
simultaneously and go overseas and do it
as well I want to leave this world
better than what it was when I found it
that's the reason why I do the things
that I do and on top of that you know
they there's no formality in terms of
how much mammograms cost like a
mammogram in North Carolina it'd be
twice as much as a mammogram in
Pennsylvania so there's no set price for
mammograms so that's my ultimate goal is
to give 50/50 three strong for Sandra
mammograms all 50 states and in the
world I'm so sorry you went through all
the devastating loss in your life but
what you're doing with that loss and
turning it around and trying to be
positive is an amazing thing so thank
you so much I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this